[Music]
you've made it to the last lab in the
quest after you complete this lab on
quick labs you will finally unlock your
badge so let's just get right to it
in this episode we'll be talking about
Google compute engine Google compute
engine delivers virtual machines running
in Google's innovative data centers and
worldwide fiber network compute engines
tooling and workflow support enables
scaling from instances to global load
balanced cloud computing compute engines
VMs boot quickly come with persistent
disk storage and deliver consistent
performance our virtual servers are
available in many configurations
including predefined sizes or the option
to create custom machine types optimized
for your specific needs in this hands-on
lab you'll learn how to launch a Windows
Server instance on Google compute engine
and connect to it using the remote
desktop protocol if you aren't using
Windows on your local machine install a
third-party RDP client such as Chrome
RDP by fusion labs one more thing that I
personally love about Google compute
engine is that our infrastructure is
entirely carbon-neutral our global
network of data centers consume 50
percent less energy than the typical
data center and we purchase enough
renewable energy to match 100% of the
energy consumed by our little operations
we are growing our global data center
footprint so your applications can run
closer to your customers and distribute
geographically for resiliency I think
that's pretty cool and is this it is
this the last lab on your quest
congratulations we want to hear from you
tell us about your experience following
this quick labs quest and how you're
applying what you've learned in your own
applications in the comments below show
up your badge and tag us on social media
see you next time
Oh